aquí
[Música]
mi nombre es breve y yo soy diseñador
experiencia
queda claro si yo sé lo que muchos están
pensando
qué demonios es un diseñador de
experiencias y para qué sirve y más para
la industria financiera
para mis amigos de la universidad
básicamente soy darth vader soy la 'alta
traición' como que trabaja en un banco
que aburrido hay también hay un poco de
preocupación como dije hay breve que le
puedo ayudar yo le puedo conseguir un
trabajito en una agencia de publicidad
no a mi me gusta mi trabajo
para la mayoría de las compañeras del
banco soy un extraterrestre un
extraño qué idioma habla qué hace para
qué sirve
lo que les cuento es que en realidad soy
más similar a la mujer maravilla lo que
sí compartimos es que ambas solucionamos
problemas problemas tal vez un poco
distintos yo solucionó un problema de
negocio con base en los sentimientos de
las personas suena un poco en vigo les
voy a explicar
ahora si hablamos del diseño de
experiencias como una rama de diseño hay
que entender el núcleo o lo que lo hace
funcionar el diseño emocional diseño
emocional es lo que lo hace todo
funcional y bueno y qué es el diseño
emocional
empecemos por la palabra diseño cuando
les digo diseño y que piensan que se
imaginan
probablemente algo así
alguien artístico que sabe dibujar
muchas veces la palabra creativo
se piensa como esto alguien que tiene
estas habilidades muchas veces si una
correlación pero no se trata de esto no
es sólo hacer las cosas bonitas
esta es una palabra que yo me inventé y
creo que ha ocurrido mucho con el diseño
látex intelectualización y qué quiere
decir esto la percepción de que los
diseñadores no son intelectuales no son
muy racionales no somos el nerd y yo es
de moliner dijo de los anteojos somos
los intuitivos los que yo agarro un
lienzo y me expreso y ya no tengo que
pensar mucho les cuento que no hay que
pensar mucho yo les vengo a decir que
diseñar es planear
si buscan en un diccionario la palabra
diseño es un plan son sinónimos ahora
qué hacemos cuando planeamos
prevemos en el futuro todo lo que puede
pasar para lograr un objetivo o
solucionar un problema y eso lo que
hacemos los diseñadores les voy a poner
un ejemplo
esa salsa de tomate esa botella es el
primer diseño que saco heinz no sé hace
cuántos años y probablemente el
diseñador cuando le pidieron que hiciera
la botella vio todo lo que había en el
mercado y dijo bueno si una botellita de
vidrio se ve bonito
está bien matándolo pero no planeo no
previó cómo era que iban a usar las
personas esa botella salsa de tomate qué
es lo que pasa con esta botella que
cuando se va acabando la salsa tienes
que darle la vuelta y pegarle y hacer un
desastre dejar la botella y como
inclinada recostar contra la pared para
poder seguir usando entonces el rediseño
de esta botella es así sigo mucho causan
cual está mejor la plana porque si
planearon y si previeron todo lo que
podría salir mal entonces quiero
dejarles esto el buen diseño es el que
planea y el mal diseño es el que es
intuitivo un diseñador que no planea que
nada más hace porque le parece bien no
lo está haciendo metido ok entonces
quiero que se queden vamos con eso el
diseño es planear
ahora
que es una emoción
la emoción es una reacción biológica que
sucede en el cuerpo
como respuesta a un estímulo externo
todo lo que entra por nuestros cinco
sentidos que aprendemos en la escuela
entonces por ejemplo yo voy caminando y
entro a un cuarto oscuro y me paralizó y
se me hace la participación
algo en mi cuerpo que pasa también se
nos contraen los músculos de la cara
tenemos lenguaje corporal y sudamos ver
hay diferentes respuestas en el cuerpo
ahora el sentimiento es lo que le sigue
a la emoción el sentimiento la mente
procesando eso que siente el cuerpo y le
pone un nombre es el quiere que se uy es
un miedo o wii
eso es confianza verdad lo entiende
entonces el sentimiento sale de una
parte racional la emoción sale
totalmente del subconsciente
no lo pensamos nada más pasa
ok ahora juntemos esas dos definiciones
diseño planear entonces diseño emocional
es planear los estímulos o condiciones
para provocar un sentimiento como debe
ser algo para que alguien sienta se
sienta cierta forma si hablamos de una
experiencia básicamente es la sumatoria
de todos los sentimientos que tiene una
persona a través del tiempo al utilizar
algo ya sea un producto o un servicio
entonces el diseño de experiencias con
tenemos las definiciones es planear para
provocar ciertas emociones a través del
tiempo mientras una persona utiliza algo
interactúa con algo como debe ser esa
secuencia interacciones para que se
sientan de tal forma
les dejo la pregunta como creen que se
sienten los clientes cuando interactúan
con un banco
muchas veces así muchas veces hay enojo
y frustración
muchas veces hay confusión
adiós
además de eso les cuento que entran en
sentimientos más serios que estos que
los bancos forman una parte muy
importante de la vida de las personas lo
que les voy a enseñar ahorita son citas
reales de usuarios que salieron de
investigación vean este los bancos o los
llaman a cobrarle a uno no les importa
que uno haya perdido su trabajo plan que
es serio
hay que empatizar con esta persona aquí
ya es preocupación es ansiedad tristeza
inclusive veamos a esta otra el cajero
no me depositó el dinero ese dinero era
de mi jefe no sé qué voy a hacer
nadie me resuelve eso está un poquito
más serio no les parece
aquí hay desesperación e impotencia ante
un servicio que nosotros le estamos
brindando un servicio que nosotros
diseñamos
ahora sí ok tenemos que hacerlo sentir
bien
pero cómo hacemos para saber qué es lo
que los hace sentir bien a los clientes
a los usuarios
suena super obvio de lo que me hace
sentir bien a me va a hacer sentir bien
a los demás
a mi hermana
no resulta que no no podemos saber que
lo que hace sentir bien a los demás si
no investigamos
esta imagen que sigue mi favorito
que se le queme en la retina quiero que
lo recuerden para siempre usted no es el
usuario okey usted no puede tomar
decisiones sin saber que lo que piensan
los demás
la próxima vez que tengan una brillante
idea recuerden si yo no soy el usuario
es más si se quedan con esto
representaciones de félix ahora qué es
lo que hacemos nosotros
investigación de usuario los y los
diseñadores investigamos imagínense que
desde ahí es porque esa imagen es un
usuario ok entonces todo lo que está por
encima del lago la parte más pequeño es
toda la información que sí tenemos y una
gran ventaja de trabajar en un banco es
que tenemos un montón de información
claro podemos ver que compran cuánto
compran con quién frecuencia compran a
dónde compran qué canales de servicio
usan etcétera pero todo lo que está por
debajo es por qué
porque deciden hacer lo que hacen y eso
es lo que no se puede ver con encuestas
o con números y eso es lo que hacemos
nosotros los diseñadores de experiencia
me gusta hacer la metáfora que somos los
buzos que van a ver por debajo de ese
aspecto y cómo lo hacemos
con diferentes metodologías hay una que
la que más utilizamos son entrevistas a
profundidad lo que busca es entender eso
es porque entonces hacemos sesiones
extendidas con usuarios de una hora hora
y media donde usamos guías de
investigación diseñados por
investigadores sociales que están
diseñados para extraer la información
más relevante estos son unos ejemplos de
estudios que hemos hecho contextuales en
las casas de la gente en la oficina a la
gente
ahora bueno hacemos todas esas
entrevistas y cómo se come eso qué
hacemos
tenemos un montón de metodologías donde
empezamos a depurar todos esos datos
usamos excel los diseñadores usamos
excel si sacamos los datos hacemos mapas
de afinidad hacemos mapas de calor
etcétera y estos son fotos de la oficina
donde parece una pared de investigación
criminal fotos de la gente
y con todo lo que sacamos con eso con
base en eso podemos diseñar servicios y
productos ahora sí
les voy a contar de un ejemplo de un
proyecto que trabajamos hace unos meses
no sé si conocen el atm full es de
cajero automático donde se pueden hacer
retiros tanto como depósitos ok entonces
este cajero tiene un equipo o una ranura
donde ese depósito se retira entonces el
negocio
quería poner uno de sus tres iconos
veamos los rojos
entonces que hicimos fuimos a probarlos
con usuarios
en estas fotos
hicimos prototipos de papel de cero
finalidad cero costos baratísimos y
vamos a probar con textualmente en las
sucursales para ver si se entendían sí
cuál de estos es la mejor opción
adivinen cuál fue la mara opción ninguna
obviamente tuvimos que reiterar dice
agarrar ese diseño entender qué fue lo
que no entendieron hacer otra versión ir
a probarlo hacer otra versión ir a
probar hasta llegar a la mejor opción
vean lo que hace lo que terminó
es esto es ahorita están todos los
cajeros full
vea cuánto cambio
en un solo día de trabajo con costo
básicamente cero
ahora porque no debería importar los
sentimientos de los clientes
puede que de abrir para igual lo estamos
haciendo dinero porque importa vean qué
importante está comprobado que los seres
humanos tomamos decisiones y
racionalmente como es el ratón que va
por el queso aunque sabe que lo van a
aplastar o sea tomamos decisiones con
base en nuestras emociones o con base en
nuestros sentimientos esto es un caso
que yo siempre me pregunta
porque alguien iría a una sucursal
física cuando pueden hacerlo digital
porque yo voy a hacer una fila
si lo papá a ver el saldo la tarjeta por
ejemplo si lo puedo hacer en el celular
no nacional no tiene sentido y
probablemente es por algún sentimiento
verdad eso miedo al canal digital o una
sensación de familiaridad la sucursal
física me gusta ir a hablar con mi
cajero favorito hay que entender pueden
haber muchas razones sentimentales o
emocionales como raíz de importante esto
dependiendo de cómo me siento mi cerebro
funciona de formas diferentes si yo
estoy ansioso economía uso una forma de
procesar de enfoque eso quiere decir que
me enfoco en una sola cosa y luego veo y
lo veo hasta que funcione
versos cuando estoy feliz sobre la jad
soy más abierta a ver a observar y es
aquí donde puedo resolver problemas es
aquí donde surge la creatividad ahora
imagínense un cliente que nunca ha usado
algo digital va y se mete a la banca
electrónica y le salen mil botones y
palabras que nunca había escuchado cómo
se va a sentir
ansioso probablemente y qué va a pasar
va a usar el procesamiento de enfoque y
va a estar un solo botón 15 veces hasta
que se frustra y no lo va a volver a
usar
ahora las emociones de finning mis
recuerdos les voy a poner un ejemplo yo
me recuerdo de lo más delicioso que me
comí ese no sé es un patacón consar
manual bajado delicioso también me
acuerdo de estos pinchos de insectos que
están contables asquerosos y todo lo que
estuvo en el medio todo lo que estuvo
normal
no nos acordamos tanto y ahora cuál de
estos nos acordamos más el que esto
delicioso el que stuart quero so
el asqueroso ok eso es una ventaja somos
más propensos a recordar emociones o
sentimientos negativos
la otra ventaja
es que los recuerdos generan
conversación entonces esos pinchos
asquerosos que me comen que hice se lo
conté a alguien cuando yo tengo un
pésimo día en el banco que voy a hacer
probablemente se lo voy a contar algo no
vayan ahí porque lo peor
le dejo otra pregunta que están diciendo
sus clientes cuando hablan de usted es
demasiado importante
normalmente trabajamos desde estos dos
elementos tenemos una objetiva negocio
quiero reducir los costos quiero
aumentar los ingresos
quiero captar más mercado quiero más
usuarios quiero más clientes entonces
pensamos tiramos unas ideas decimos sí
bueno ok hagámoslo hagamos una
plataforma digital hagamos una campaña
de mercadeo si de mari hambre buenísimo
y qué pasó
no involucraron al usuario en el proceso
y cuando no involucramos al usuario
tenemos productos y servicios que no son
deseables que no es lo que querían pero
más que no deseables pueden ser no
utilizables son demasiado difíciles o
peor aún que no era lo que necesitaban
nadie usa algo que no era realmente lo
que necesitan si olvidamos el negocio y
vemos nada el usuario y la tecnología
que pasa tenemos algo que no es rentable
no les sirve el negocio
si vemos nada más el negocio del usuario
no nos importa vamos de como simplemente
tenemos algo que no es factible y qué
hacemos con eso no sirve tampoco
entonces lo que quiero decirles hoy es
que el diseño experiencias está en el
centro está en la intersección de esas
tres partes
esa intersección es donde vive el buen
negocio
es desde aquí donde diseñamos la banca
emocional muchas gracias